good morning Hank it's Tuesday evil baby
Genghis Khan so last night longtime
nerdfighter Roxane punch posted this to
her tumblr I keep going through college
degrees and the jobs you could land with
them and I just keep going back to how
overpriced it all is is it even worth it
that's a really interesting question not
just to prospective college students but
also to people in their mid-30s still
paying off their college loans so let's
examine it now of course most people
outside of the United States will be
like of course university is worth it
University is free or at least very
inexpensive we also have subsidized
education here in the United States but
it's much less subsidized so here if you
live in Indiana for instance Indiana
University cost about ten thousand
dollars if you don't live in Indiana it
costs about thirty thousand a year so is
it worth it well let's say you spend a
hundred thousand dollars on college
including like sixty thousand in student
loans with interest you're gonna pay
about eighty thousand total on those one
so your total college cost will be a
hundred twenty thousand dollars except
you will also have spent a lot of time
writing papers and attending classes and
going to supposedly epic frat parties
that are never actually very fun because
even as you're dancing and drinking and
talking to vaguely attractive strangers
there's this omnipresent gnawing feeling
in your gut that nothing means anything
and you feel this endless existential
isolation with that just me right so
anyway you're doing all of that when you
might be working that's called
opportunity cost on the other hand the
80 thousand dollars that you spend will
actually be slightly less than 80
thousand dollars would have been because
of inflation I'm gonna ballpark here and
just say that your college cost is like
a hundred forty thousand dollars in this
example but then you have 50 ish years
of labor force drudgery to look forward
to now again we have to deal with
inflation and stuff but let's just say
that if you make 175 thousand dollars
more than you would have made then
college was worth it so how much in per
hour earnings over your career does a
college degree have to generate in order
to be worth it
about a dollar seventy-five so over the
course of your career if you make $13 an
hour on average when you would have
otherwise made 1125 College has paid for
itself and so most studies show that on
average college is still very much worth
it although I should note that there are
some for-profit universities and
misleading vocational training programs
that probably aren't worth it but
assuming you go to a reasonably good
accredited university there are two
things that are true one it is
criminally overpriced two it is probably
still worth it I think my problem is
that calculation assumes that human life
is a purely economic phenomenon which it
isn't
let me give you an example as you know
Hank a long time ago I worked the
graveyard shift at Steak and Shake and I
made about $14 an hour on average it was
a great job with good benefits there was
even a stock buying program which is why
I still own fifteen shares of Steak and
Shake stock but about once a week at 3
or 3:30 in the morning I'd walk into the
bathroom and even though the toilet was
fully functional I'd noticed that there
was vomit in the urinal now I don't know
if you've ever cleaned a stranger's
vomit out of a urinal but let me assure
you that the most intense games of
rock-paper-scissors I will ever play
were played to decide who was gonna be
on vomit urinal Duty after graduating
from college I actually made about $1
per hour less when I started working as
an assistant at bookless magazine but
the job was better in every way I was
surrounded by books and people who loved
them I had opportunities for advancement
and in six years of working there I
never once saw vomit in the urinal cake
it's been my experience that maximizing
income is a hell of a lot less important
than maximizing passion and fulfillment
in your life both professionally and
personally when I was in college I
remember theory that the dreary grind of
adulthood would feature like infinitely
more existential dread than frat parties
had but the opposite has been true for
me I'm much less likely to feel that
gnawing fear of aimlessness and nihilism
than I used to be and that's partly
because education gave me job
opportunities so it's mostly because
education gave me perspective and
context whether you're studying
Electrical Engineering or poetry college
is not finally about maximizing income
it's about becoming a better and more
informed observer of the universe and
for me at least that's what leads to a
more fulfilling life Hank in a world
where about half of humans live on less
than two dollars and fifty cents a day
the opportunity to learn and study in a
formal dedicated way is still a gift
even if it has become a very expensive
one I'll see you on Friday